si vier jahren habe ich das erste mal
alkohol konsumiert die antwort bitte in
12 13
das war später als 14
leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen
besonders dringend
so leute herzlich willkommen beim ein
video
ich habe heute zwei gäste vielleicht
wollt ihr euch einfach mal vorstellen
wie geht's euch so gut
okay wir haben einmal marie und wir
haben einen bruder und wir machen heute
eine challenge ich weiß ja dass ich
einige von euch noch daran erinnern wir
haben ja mal also juli und nicht mein
mitbewohner wir haben mit marie ein
bisschen reingelegt nehmen wir dieses
werk nicht mehr bin ich nein auch das
genau die gleiche geld genau an dem wir
dieses werken mich besser gespielt haben
nur julius zeit alle antworten schon und
mal unnötigsten antworten so was wie
lieblingsfarbe von prinz ja jemand
kurzer ausschnitt was ist die
lieblingsfarbe von meiner oma joh
komplett zur nächsten frage ich habe
zwei cousinen und von der 1
die hat zwei namen und was ist jetzt
zweiter vorname so und wir spielen das
ganze heute im original und ich bin echt
war gespannt wer mich von euch besser
kennt ich habe mir zehn fragen
rausgesucht und hier weiß keiner von den
beiden die richtigen antworten also die
weiß nur ich würde sagen wir lieber gar
nicht lange fragen direkt mal an und ich
bin sehr gespannt werden gewinnen wird
wie machen wir das dann dürfen wir also
sofort bagso ich stelle die frage und
dann erzählt sie von 321 oder und weil
dann könnte wenigstens beide auf die
gleichen antworten noch geben weiß ja
dass es dann kriegt jeder am punkt so
dass irgendwas hat sie es versteht man
so unter druck und kann nicht mal kurz
mal liegen ok dann machen wir es so ich
will doch die frage dann sage ich
123 und dafür die andere sorgen ich
hatte eigentlich jetzt angesagt mit rein
rufen aber an dir das ist besser okay
wir fangen erst mal mit einer leichteren
frage ich gehe mal etwas zurück einer
kurz spannende musik was hatte ich für
einen abiturzeugnis schnitt die
antworten in 123 dann habt ihr was sagst
du mir zweifeln
da kann man vieles richtig sony
einschnitt gesagt ja aber dass ich
dachte das müsstest du gar nicht was
hätte ich gedacht dass du das weißt du
musst mal ein bisschen lauter reden weil
sonst wird man nicht nur soweit okay so
also 14 marie ich könnte hier könnte das
auch eine person märkte 1 nur für dich
die nächste frage ich bin ja letztes
jahr nach köln gezogen und 2017 in
welchem monat im jahr 2017 wenn ich nach
köln gezogen
[Musik]
12.34 uhr gibt es für die beiden punkt
das ist 100 prozent komplett richtig 21
filme rieso willkommen zur nächsten
frage und zwar von welcher marke habe
ich die meisten t shirts no t shirt
seine eigene marke
die rede schon aber halt die atmo und
das noch dazu sagen die ich halt aktiv
trage
ok antwort den 123 fragen zur light 32
firma willkommen vielleicht zu einer
etwas schwierigeren frage und zwar wie
viele jahre habe ich in meinem leben
aktiv im fußballverein gespielt gute
frage
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage erzielt
werden da dran ist oder wer daraus dann
theoretisch genau die antwort bitte in
12 zweieinhalb 33 10 14 14
und du bist ja auch 12 12 da hätte man
doch jetzt nur mal rechts müssen ja ich
habe von drei ungefähr bis 16.17
gerechnet 3 also die antwort wäre 14
jahre ich habe von vier jahren bis 18
jahren gespielt 11 das mit 18 ich
gespielt habe ich noch also 4 2
kommen wir zur nächsten frage welche
serie es gibt nur eine serie die ich bis
jetzt komplett durch geschaut habe
welche ist das kind muss bei uns
ich dachte ich dafür soll bis 13 erster
also was soll ich zu der unter dem
slogan ja also bei dem acht runs bisher
durchgedreht ist game of thrones aber
einen hat er zuerst gesagt also ja nur
dann gehst fünf zu vier mal doch ist das
wirklich auf den punkt weil ich habe ja
nicht bis drei gezählt so kommen wir zur
nächsten frage und zwar gibt es auch
diese antwort
und zwar liebt es auf diese frage zwei
richtige antworten von welchen youtuber
schaue ich jedes video war ich weiß
nicht von diesem amerikanischen youtuber
der diese blogs nach der so eine größere
nase hat die antwort könnte
13 und dieser ja ich weiß noch nicht die
namen und dieser eile da der diese
travel videos macht ihr könnt geraten
ja ich kenne kein youtube du kannst ja
so ein paar youtube wo ich selber
irgendwie ich keine ahnung ich so viele
youtube macht jeder mal eine antwort
hier sonst gibt es dafür keinen punkt
recherchen der frischen windes video
gucken nicht kennen können jetzt lassen
wir doch öfter mal diese videos geguckt
die die getrampelt oder greifen
ach so ja das habe ich gerne wenn man
reist also ihr sagt die geschenke und du
sagst ich kenne aber das ist halt kein
punkt großen und locken und fair ist die
richtige antwort wäre etwas billig der
nachsitzung ja sagst ja richtig ja also
einmal von dem das ist ich glaube
schwede aber der macht amerikanische
blogs oder englische blogs und her und
gucke eigentlich auch jetzt also es
steht 6 2 536 zu drei so in nur vier
punkte
1964 in frage und die lautet wie oft war
ich dieses jahr schon im urlaub als wie
oft war ich schon weg in einer anderen
stadt längere zeit also die antwort
deutlich schlechter einzeln die antwort
bitte in 1 23 mal so wenn in berlin vor
neujahr noch dazu zählen also ich hab
gesagt hat schon weg von köln aus in
diesem jahr am 3 ich ziehe jetzt als
urlaub nicht wenn ich mal zwei tage und
berlin bin und kein arm video
aufzunehmen so ist ja keine nur sein
land einmal hätten sie sind dreimal so
die antwort wäre vier mal warum einmal
in rom dann in österreich dann in
santorini und gegen dingen sehen hier
österreich noch mal genau das ist nur
ein profi kein mann seid ihr doch kommen
wir zur nächsten frage welche klamotten
marke finde ich zurzeit wirklich sehr
gut also welche klamotten wagen feiere
ich so am meisten zu zweit marke oder
habe ich noch gesagt marke die antwort
bitte in 1 zahlreich umfragetief ja das
ist ja was anderswo weil ich von adidas
die meisten t shirts heißt ja nicht dass
ja dass am tollsten findet 1.650 kommen
wir zur nächsten frage und zwar was für
einem maße hat mein neues bett doch
keine ahnung antwortet antwort wird den
123 einmal 2
du hast auch zweimal zwei tagen also auf
jeden fall
doch zweimal zwei ungefähr ja ungefähr
zehn kann ich so beides falsch 1 meter
80 mal zu arbeiten aber ich dachte so
die länger als 80 mit zwei solcher hass
aber nicht ein so dass schon immer noch
sechs zu fünf kommen wir zur letzten
frage die ich mir hier notiert und zwar
in welchem jahr habe ich mein abitur
gemacht antwort bitte in 1230 16
das gesagt okay dann schützt ja jetzt
eigentlich käme sagen jetzt einfach als
chic 66 okay bei merlin dass er gesagt
hat und ich überlege mir so eine frage
zum stechen zu stechen
ich muss mal kurz überlegen hatte bereit
für die masters jetzt sehe jetzt alle
punkte doppelt und zwar mit wieviel
jahren habe man das ist immer so blöd
beerdigt wie vier jahren habe ich das
erste mal alkohol konsumiert die antwort
bitte in 12 13
das war später als 14
was sagst du trommelwirbel für die alles
entscheidende antwort
jetzt sagt was ja würde ich mir
überlegen welche politik das war ja
keine ahnung dass es thief den 15
und damit haben wir ein gewinner oder
eine gewinnerin richtig von nina
verloren
ich habe ja das ganze war mit 15 und
zwar war ich da 15 jahre alt ich habe
das erst mal alkohol mit 14 probiert
also sowohl bierchen getrunken oder auch
mal zwei aber zu viel watt ist das erste
mal mit 15 jahren sollte das war es mit
diesem video ich doch gut geschlagen
dafür dass wir uns im jahr kennen es ist
richtig ich hoffe dadurch die nicht
ich habe natürlich ist hat euch gefallen
lassen gerne einen daumen nach oben
dafür noch ein paar und gerne den beiden
auf instagram ist hier mal eingeladen
ihr müsst ihr nicht folgen ich hab eh
schon genug verloren nicht was ja leute
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
kandidiert hierzu flügel einen blinden
flügel bei dir ja warum heute haut rein
wollten versand zum schluss zittern